As exciting as our little
one by one widget is,
there just isn't enough room to
show everything you might want.
The ability to resize widgets gives
you the flexibility to share almost
all of your code, yet give users
the flexibility to choose how much space
they want your widget to take up.
Remember our design in the beginning?
A two by one widget would give
our icon the full height.
And we'll use the same styling
as listItems within sunshine for
the high and low temperature.
For wider widgets, we'll show
the description of the weather as well.
Since we'll be sharing as much code as
we can, make sure common elements, like
the image and high temperature text us
the same IDs across all three layouts.
So how do we know what layout to use?
On Android 4.0 and lower devices, we
know the size will always be our default
size, but on Android 4.1 and
higher devices, we'll take advantage of
a new method added to AppWidget Manager,
getAppWidgetOptions.
This takes a widget ID, and returns it
to bundle, which contains information,
such as current size
of that widget in dp.
With that information,
we can easily switch between layouts
by comparing the widget's width
to specific values, denoting
the break points between our layouts.
In fact, we can use two new attributes
added to app widget provider info.
minResizeHeight and minResizeWidth.
These let you set a minimum size
that's smaller than the default size.
With this, we can make our
default the two by one widget,
and allow users to resize down to a one
by one if they're crunched for space.
This is great for ensuring that you
put the best experience forward
while maintaining flexibility.
We'll also add one more method
to our AppWidgetProvider,
onAppWidgetOptionsChanged.
This is called whenever the size
of the widget is changed.
In our case,
similar to our onReceive and
onUpdate method, we'll start the intent
service to refresh our widget.